بدأت الدفعة الأخيرة بعد غروب الشمس مباشرة
يوم السبت
عندما توغلت القوات الديمقراطية السورية المدعومة من الولايات المتحدة
في طريقها إلى المدينة التي ورائي
باجوس الفولكاني ، وهي آخر
معقل
لداعش في سوريا أو العراق
الآن أخبرنا الضباط هنا
أن هناك  قد يصل عددهم
إلى 1500 مدني داخل المدينة على الرغم من أن
ما رأيناه خلال الأسابيع القليلة الماضية
هو أن الناس يغادرون
إما وهم يدفعون ثمن طريقهم للخروج أو يتسللون
خارج البلدة.
أن هناك ما يصل إلى
من بعض مقاتلي داعش الأكثر تشددًا في القتال على
الرغم من أننا نسمع أيضًا أن
هناك قتالًا داخليًا
بين هؤلاء المقاتلين هناك أولئك
الذين قرروا بعد أسابيع من الضربات الجوية المستمرة للتحالف وكذلك قصف المدفعية والهاون
أن الوقت قد حان  على الاستسلام
والآخرين الذين يصرون على أن الوقت قد حان
للقتال حتى الموت ، لذا فإن ما رأيناه
طوال المساء هو أن طائرات التحالف
تحلق في سماء المنطقة وتضرب أهدافًا على بعد
قرابة
اثنين كي  كيلومترات من هنا بالإضافة إلى
نيران مدفع رشاش ثقيل ومستمر إلى حد ما بالإضافة إلى نيران
المدفعية والصواريخ التي تصل إلى المدينة
لا يبدو أن هناك مقاومة كبيرة
حتى الآن ولكن قيل لنا أنه في الصباح
هو الوقت المناسب
لداعش  هجوم أنا بن
ويدمان أبلغ من خارج بهوسل فوكاني في
شرق سوريا